so many college quarterbacks are good
enough at the college level you really
don't know until you get to the nfl
level what a guy's gonna do and that
brings me to chad kelly a guy that was
mr irrelevant i hate that term too the
last guy taken in the draft two years
ago by the denver broncos as of last
year he had climbed the number two on
the depth chart ugly incident at a von
miller-hosted halloween party where chad
kelly got kicked out and then he went
into somebody's house and that he
doesn't know and sat down on the couch
and and got chased off with the tube of
a vacuum cleaner got arrested for a
criminal trespass pleaded guilty to
misdemeanor charges back in march the
colts reportedly are taking a look at
him i'm told the colts haven't made a
decision yet they may do so this week
there's that frank reich jim kelly
connection so maybe a second chance or
the case may be a third chance for chad
kelly and you know chris i'm gonna say
what i say about tyree kill and every
other guy that gets a a second third
fourth chance whatever
every time you give someone a second
chance you're taking away someone else's
first chance even now with a 90-man
off-season roster there was a
quarterback from central connecticut
that was going to be signed by the colts
and the colts said now we're not going
to do it we may be signing chad kelly so
that's a now that guy landed with
cincinnati but he took a job that
somebody else would have gotten in
cincinnati there's all when you give
that guy the second chance whether it's
an offseason roster spot or regular
season you're taking away someone else's
first chance typically someone who never
got himself into trouble and that's one
of the philosophical issues that the nfl
needs to continue to confront yeah it's
it's a tough balance uh it's it's hard
to argue the points you made there but
the the great equalizer and all that is
talent you know guys with big time
talent seem to get second and third
chances yeah i mean chad kelly had
issues at clemson had a transfer to ole
miss had issues at ole miss made him
fall out of the draft you know then of
course becomes mr irrelevant and then of
course you talked about the issue with
the denver broncos but man the way the
way chad kelly played in the preseason
last year and all those things uh yeah
they're gonna make teams notice because
chad kelly has nfl's starting potential
as far as his physical abilities you
know he's a big guy's an incredibly
strong arm can make some really
eye-popping type of throws that's going
to get the attention of gm's and as you
know in life uh it's not always what you
know it's who you know and yeah i'm sure
that the frank reich jim kelly
combination is certainly not hurting
here in this issue uh but but i i get
your point yeah there's guys that uh are
certainly not getting their first chance
where we see other guys in the nfl
rightly wrongly whatever it may be might
be on their third or fourth chance but i
think the big thing there is the talent
and uh talent sometimes guts lets a lot
of things get swept under the rug
i'm a little surprised that it's taken
as long as it has for chad kelly's name
to come up when you consider the talent
when you consider the connection when
you consider he was number two on the
depth chart in denver and had all
indications of of playing at some point
last year i mean if he hadn't been
kicked off the team i think at some
point they would have rolled the dice on
chad kelly just from an excitement
standpoint let's see what this guy can
do and the aaf co-founder bill paulian
he he said that chad kelly was the best
quarterback in the draft in 2017 and
that draft class included deshaun watson
and patrick mahomes for crying out loud
and they didn't show him any type of of
interest but i just think it's a matter
of time before he plays again because
you're right talent is always going to
rule the day
and uh it should it be that way
well no but that's kind of the way it is
in sports at every level in every type
of sport the better you are
the more leeway you have the more rules
you can break because ultimately people
want to win
and they're going to give you that
chance to help them win
knowing that if it doesn't work out well
all right we'll just get ready anyway
right exactly right i mean yeah i mean
hey go through it you know does randy
moss get away with some of the things he
got away with in minnesota if he's not
randy moss that you know lawrence taylor
get away with some of the things he got
away with in new york uh you know well
yeah he got away with them because he
was you know
sacking quarterbacks every other time
they drop back to pass so yeah that is
part of the deal and it's just like any
profession too you know the the the
really great talents they get favored in
their business and their prospective
jobs whatever it may be uh and here you
know the other thing that i think you
know again shows chris ballard's gene
chris ballard's genius here you know and
you talked about it i think during the
show today yeah uh jacoby bersett is
this the last year of his contract he's
going to be a free agent i think he
knows if i sent a chad kelly or
something like that man and somebody
went down late in july or late in august
or early season jacoby persec could be a
hot commodity as far as a trade
commodity and that's where i think chris
ballard's probably thinking about this
chad kelly signing as well
we need to wrap it for now but chris on
this point of giving guys second and
third chances based on talent and that
intoxication that comes from talent
think about this for tomorrow read the
item that i posted saturday at pft is it
time for the nfl to begin to create a
disincentive and take away future draft
picks for players
who do have that second chance and it
blows up
is that the appropriate way to give
teams reason to think twice before they
do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports